Như xem mấy lưu bếp nhé, phía li quà đặc đường đang sử chúa.
Thì cũng lúc nào mỗi người.
Sư bệnh giễn ra gần thải tháng nay, đoạn qua phượng lông thành.
Trong quá trình sử chúa, đơn vị thí công cách nặt đường,
tạo giảnh dọng khoảng 50% tìm mát,
sau gần 40% tìm mát, rồi tạm dừng, tạo thành các ổ gà,
khiến xem mấy mất lạy, tạy nhá, phía li quà.
Ngày ngọt bố tế, phương ngày năm 2019,
rồi, đường gặn đường thì giúp bố, đúng không?
Các bạn có thể đúng không?
Chúng không?
Lánh đạo sử xe dực đồng này cho biết,
sẽ chỉ đạo đơn vị thí công, kìm chá hiệt dường,
khắc phục sẽ đường và bảo đam ăn bọn râu thông.
Pốc lộn năm 2020, kết nối thành phố ổ chí mình,
đồng này và cũng càng kế mếp thị vài.
Dính đường thường xuyên có lựa xe tài,
xe công tên ở lớn, nên nhiều đạo xuân cấp, phải sự chứa.